well it looks like Marvel Studios and
Disney really are about to change the
way they do Disney plus content and not
just Disney plus content but of course
movies as well however just because
they're changing things doesn't mean
they still don't have plans for some
awesome projects because they do but
what is really going to change is how
these projects are executed but today we
have word that Marvel Studios is
considering many different Heroes and
teams for Disney plus projects and they
sound really really exciting and how
they released these Disney plus projects
is going to be from what it sounds like
a little bit different than what we're
used to so far it won't necessarily be a
full Disney plus series but not
necessarily just be a special
presentation either Marvel and Disney
are getting very serious about releasing
better content in fact in a recent
article published by deadline they quote
Bob Iger stating quality over quantity
and Bob Iger also said I spent the year
with the team fix fixing a lot of things
so Disney and Marvel Studios are on the
move to make better content and we'll
talk about how they're going to switch
things up and which projects they are
considering for their own Disney plus
we'll call them show still so if you
want to stay up to date on all things
MCU be sure to subscribe to the channel
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month only 2 days left in this
month for the giveaway so be sure to
enter so like we mentioned it looks like
Bob Iger has been spending a lot of time
trying to pinpoint what exactly was
going wrong with the studio and took a
year to try and essentially fix it now I
know some people would say well we just
got the Marvels we got some other
projects that weren't that good but
those projects have been in development
for a very long time so we're probably
not looking at past projects but moving
forward going into the future now with
what we are about to get that's where
we're really looking to see the impr
Improvement that could have been done
and at this point it's been made pretty
clear that Marvel and Disney are kind of
experimenting on what could really work
for Disney plus they are releasing the
echo series all at once so not one
episode per week but the whole series is
dropping on one day and then for
Marvel's what if animated series season
2 they are releasing one episode per day
for nine consecutive days so they're
trying different things they're seeing
what works they're seeing if this is
better than releasing one episode per
week but again like I mentioned in the
beginning this isn't going to stop them
from making Disney plus content and
according to a recent report it sounds
like they have some pretty awesome
projects in the works at least some that
they are considering according to a
recent report from Insider Daniel rpk
right now Marvel Studios is exploring
different characters for potential
Disney plus series and there's a lot of
names listed here but let's go ahead and
start off with the last thing that is
said in this report which is Select
members of the X-Men so Marvel Studios
right now is looking at X-Men characters
to make Disney plus projects about now
this does line up with what we have
recently heard we have heard that right
now Kevin foggy and Marvel Studios are
speaking with writers and trying to hire
writers to write X-Men stories for the
MCU now we assumed that this would be an
X-Men movie however we most likely are
going to be getting Disney plus projects
about the X-Men before X-Men films and
it actually is a pretty great way to
introduce some X-Men before or they make
their way to the big screen because
let's face it there are a lot of X-Men
and if you are going to bring an X-Men
team together in the MCU for an X-Men
film and want everybody to truly know
each X-Men character and want to know
what they're about well having some
Disney plus projects be about them is a
great way to go I think one of Marvel
studios's biggest problems right now is
the fact that they keep trying to get us
to care about characters and
relationships in these movies however we
don't really care that much because
they're not giving us that much time
with these characters to explore their
relationships well having some X-Men
appear in Disney plus projects before
would do that they would help us get to
know these characters and the
relationships they have that way we
would actually care about them because
we've spent enough time with them now
Daniel rpk does not mention any specific
X-Men they just say select members of
the X-Men so this could really be about
anybody and I'm assuming it'll be
multiple projects since it's about
individual characters select members not
the team as a whole and a lot of people
also assume that we will be dealing with
sort of a younger X-Men and I think a
first class story would be the way to go
obviously Kevin foge would do it way
different than Fox did it but I love the
idea of having an X-men group led by
Cyclops with Professor X in the
background of course just like in the
comics but Cyclops really being the
leader and with him we could have Iceman
Beast Angel Jean Gray the Scarlet Witch
could even be incorporated into the
story of this new X-Men team there's a
lot of great ways you could go with this
and if Kevin really does want to make it
different and not focus on Professor X
Magneto put them in the spotlight right
away they could focus on the first class
team which means we could be getting
projects about Cyclops Beast Etc but
also at the same time it would be really
cool to see the story of Professor X and
Magneto in the MCU but we'll have to
wait and see what Marvel Studios has
planned but go ahead and let me know
which X-Men you would love to see a
Disney plus project about in the
comments down below now Daniel rpk also
mentions other people other Heroes and
some really not so Heroes like The
Punisher we know the Punisher is
returning and Daredevil born again and
we do know that the Punisher series on
Netflix is loved by many many fans so it
would make sense that Marvel Studios
would consider the Punisher for a Disney
Plus show in the MCU with John Bernthal
of course returning to play the iconic
Punisher another one Daniel rpk
mentioned is Ghost Rider now we've heard
that there was a Ghost Rider special
presentation in the works at Marvel
Studios for some time now so this makes
sense it does seem like Marvel Studios
really is trying to get Ghost Rider into
the MCU in some way shape or form and if
we consider the fact that it does look
like they are setting up that kind of
darker side of the MCU and trying to set
up the Midnight Sun side of the MCU with
blade Ghost Rider Doctor Strange
moonight Deadpool Etc it makes sense to
get Ghost Rider in the MCU kind of ASAP
at this point and there are many others
that Daniel rpk includes like Alpha
flight runaways Jessica Jones keep in
mind he saying that Marvel Studios right
now is exploring different characters
they could make Disney Plus shows about
so this isn't saying these characters
are confirmed to get their own shows but
Marvel Studios is really looking for the
right characters to make the right show
about or maybe not even a show like I
mentioned in the beginning Marvel
Studios does seem to be kind of changing
how they're going to be doing Disney
plus we've had previous reports this
week stating that Wonderman and Vision
Quest are still in development but are
reportedly going to be limited ited
Series this is also coming from Daniel
rpk and this means that Marvel is
somewhat trying a middle ground between
a special presentation and a full-on
series this would be new for Disney plus
and Marvel Studios but might work
especially for the ones that seem a
little bit too dragged out like secret
Invasion could have been a limited
series it could have been a little bit
quicker paced and that might have made
it better even though the ending
probably would have been the same but
overall would have picked up the pace
and probably made it more exciting and
this could be the case for a lot of
stories they want to do in Disney plus
because not everything needs a 6 episode
9 episode story or event but also at the
same time some stories can't be told
with just a 45 minute to an hour and a
half special presentation but could
require 2 45 minute or 3 45 minute
episodes on Disney plus to tell a full
story and it could also really excite
people to know that they don't have to
wait six episodes nine episodes to
figure out what exactly is going to
happen in a series but you could get
your anticipation really really high and
your excitement up really really high
knowing that you watch one episode and
there are only two more left not five
more or eight more so this strategy
really could help Disney plus and Marvel
Studios doing limited series instead of
full blown out series but hey go ahead
and let us know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below would
this make you more excited and more
inclined to watch a show if it wasn't so
many episodes long let us know what you
think in the comments don't forget to
like the video and subscribe stay up to
dat on the MCU and enter our giveaway
only 2 days left you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof